FIGHT SURROUNDING HIS
NOMINATION, MIER IF VENT HOPE IS
THAT -- MY FERVENT HOPE IS THAT
BRETT KAVANAUGH WILL WORK TO
LESSEN THE DIVISIONS IN THE
SUPREME COURT.
SO THAT WE HAVE NAR FEWER 5-4
DECISIONS, FAR FEWER.
SO THAT PUBLIC CONFIDENCE, IN
OUR JUDICIARY AND OUR HIGHEST
COURT, IS RESTORED.
>> Sean: MORE SENATOR SUSAN
COLLINS CRITICIZING THE
PARTISANSHIP THROUGHOUT THE
KAVANAUGH CONFIRMATION HEARING,
HER, HOPE THAT JUSTICE KAVANAUGH
WILL RESTORE OUR SYSTEM.
SENATOR TED CRUISE, IN 32 DAYS
ARE YOU ON THE BALLOT.
>> YES.
>> Sean: GOING UP AGAINST,
WHAT’S HIS NAME, BETO O’ROARKE,
I KEEP READING A CULT FIGURE.
IN SPITE OF AWFUL THINGS HE’S
WRITTEN ABOUT WOMEN, A, AND
APPARENTLY ACCORDING TO A POLICE
REPORT GOT A DUI AND LIED ABOUT
LEAVING THE SCENE OF AN
ACCIDENT, ACCORDING TO THE
REPORT.
HOW WOULD HE VOTE IN THE SENATE,
WOULD HE VOTE FOR SENATOR
SCHUMER, WOULD HE HAVE VOTED
AGAINST JUDGE KAVANAUGH?
>> BETO O’ROARKE IS A HARD KNOW
ON BRETT KAVANAUGH.
HE WAS A HARD NO BEFORE THE
ALLEGATIONS, HE’S A HARD NO NOW.
HE’S RUNNING A FAR LEFT CAMPAIGN
LIKE ELIZABETH WARREN, BERNIE
SANDERS.
TODAY WAS A GOOD DAY.
TOMORROW, JUDGE BRETT KAVANAUGH
IS GOING TO BECOME JUSTICE BRETT
KAVANAUGH.
BUT WE WON BY THE SLIMMEST OF
MARGINS.
IT’S WHY THIS ELECTION MATTERS,
WHY IT MATTERS THAT WE COP OUT
AND STAND UP.
THE SMEAR CAMPAIGN, WE HAVE
SEEN, PARTICULARLY IN THE LAST
TWO WEEKS HAS BEEN A NEW AND
DISGRACEFUL LOW FOR THE UNITED
STATES SENATE.
IT’S NOT ACCEPTABLE TO JUST GO
AFTER AND SLANDER JUDGE
KAVANAUGH, SLANDER HIS FAMILY.
FEET HIS KIDS TO THIS KIND OF
HORRIFIC ABUSE.
IT’S NOT RIGHT.
>> Sean: SENATOR, I LIVE IN
NEW YORK, ROUGH AND TUMBLE, OF
NEW YORK.
PROBABLY A LITTLE MORE STREET
WISE THAN I SHOULD BE IN LIFE.
BUT I’D RATHER LIVE IN TEXAS,
BECAUSE YOU PAY NO STATE INCOME
TAXES.
AND NEW YORK STATE --.
WE’D LOVE TO HAVE YOU, SEAN.
>> Sean: I WANT TO ASK THIS.
YOU’VE BEEN IN ROUGH AND TUMBLE
RACES.
YOU AND THE PRESIDENT HAVE
DISAGREEMENTS.
YOU HAVE SUPPORTED THE AGENDA OF
THE BIGGEST TAX CUT, SECURING
OUR BORDERS.
>> ABSOLUTELY.
>> Sean: CONSERVATIVE
ORIGINALIST ON THE SUPREME
COURT.
YOU ARE KNOWN FOR YOUR NL OF THE
CONSTITUTION, YOUR KNOWLEDGE.
WHAT DO YOU MAKE OF THE DANGERS,
IF THIS BEHAVIOR WERE TO BE
REWARDED?
>> WELL, WHAT WE’VE SEEN IN THE
LAST TWO YEARS IS THE EXTREME
LEFT, IS JUST FILLED WITH RAGE,
THEY’RE FILLED WITH ANGER,
THEY’RE FILLED WITH HATRED FOR
PRESIDENT TRUMP.
IT’S SPILLING OUT, IT’S SPILLING
OUT IN NASTY AND ANGRY PROTESTS
DURING THE KAVANAUGH HEARING.
FIRST DAVE OF THE HEARING, 07
PEOPLE WERE ARRESTED WITH THE
ACTIVE COMPLICITY OF DEMOCRATIC
SENATORS.
JUST YESTERDAY, 300 PEOPLE WERE
ARRESTED AT THE CAPITOL.
WE’RE SEEING AN ANGER,
BITTERNESS.
YOU KNOW, THIS WEEK WE HAD SOME
ONE SEND WHITE POWDER TO OUR
CAMPAIGN OFFICE IN TEXAS THAT
ENDED UP HAVING HAZ-MAT AND THE
FBI CALLED IN BECAUSE THE
CONCERN WAS THAT IT WAS ANTHRAX.
TURNED OUT TO BE NEGATIVE.
BUT WE’RE IN THIS ENVIRONMENT
WHERE THERE’S AN ANGER, A RAGE,
A FURY, AND IT’S WRONG.
IT IS WRONG TO JUST SMEAR SOME
ONE’S CHARACTER LIKE THEY HAVE
DONE ON TO JUDGE KAVANAUGH.
IT’S WRONG TO DO WHAT THE
DEMOCRATS DID TO OUT DR. FORD.
SHE ASKED THAT THE ALLEGATIONS
BE KEPT CONFIDENTIAL.
THE CONGRESSIONAL DEMOCRATS
DIDN’T CARE, THEY OUTED HER
AGAINST HER WILL.
THAT IS WRONG.
WE HAVE TO FIND A WAY TO
DISAGREE WITH EACH OTHER BUT
STILL ENGAGE WITH CIVILITY,
TREAT EACH OTHER WITH DECENCY.
>> Sean: YOU KNOW, YOU WERE IN A
TOUGH PRIMARY WITH PRESIDENT
TRUMP.
IT’S NOT BEANBAGS.
>> SURE.
>> Sean: YOU GAVE, TOOK.
NUDZ A DEBATE AT THE END OF THE
DAY, YOU WERE ASKED, WELL, WHY
DID YOU MAKE THE DECISION TO GO
ALONG WITH THE PRESIDENT.
YOU SAID I’M HERE TO REPRESENT
THE PEOPLE OF TEXAS.
SEEMS LIKE THAT CAMPAIGN, I KNOW
THE PRESIDENT IS A DISRUPTOR, HE
BREAKS A LOT OF DISHES, BUT WE
SEE THE RESULTS, DON’T WE.
AND YOU PUT THE PEOPLE OF YOUR
STATE AHEAD.
NOTHING EVER HAS BEEN THIS BAD.
I’VE NEVER SEEN THINGS THIS
AWFUL.
>> THE ANGER, THE FURY, THE
FRANKLY THREATS OF VIOLENCE ARE
REALLY DISTURBING.
>> Sean: DUE PROCESS.
>> SENATORS, PEOPLE SHOWING UP
AT THEIR HOUSE, THREATENING
THEIR FAMILY.
IT’S NOT GOOD FOR THE COUNTRY.
AND YOU LOOK AT THIS HEARING,
THE BASIC PRINCIPLES OF DUE
PRINCIPLES OF THE PRESUMPTION OF
PROCESS, AS YOU SAID, THE BASIC
PRINCIPLES OF THE PRESUMPTION OFINNOCENCE, YOU’RE INNOCENT UNTIL
INNOCENCE, YOU’RE INNOCENT UNTIL
PROVEN GUILTY.
YOU KNOW, LISTEN, ONCE THESE
ALLEGATIONS WERE MADE THEY WERE
SERIOUS.
NEEDED TO BE TREATED WITH
RESPECT.
WE NEEDED A FULL AND FAIR
HEARING, AND WE DID.
WE NEEDED TO GIVE DR. FORD AN
OPPORTUNITY TO TREAT HER WITH
RESPECT AND WE DID.
BUT WE NEED TO GIVE JUDGE
KAVANAUGH AN OPPORTUNITY TO
DEFEND HIMSELF.
AND HE SHOULD HAVE BEEN TREATED
WERE RESPECT AND HE WASN’T.
THEY DID THEATRICS AND MOCK
THE DEMOCRATS COULDN’T, INSTEAD,
OUTRAGE.
SHOCKED, SHOCKED THAT TEENAGERS
DRINK IN HIGH SCHOOL AND
COLLEGE.
GOODNESS GRACIOUS.
AND THEY WERE EVEN MORE SHOCKED
THINGS IN THEIR YEAR -- STUPID
THAT 17-YEAR-OLDS SAY STEW PILD
THINGS IN THE YEAR BOOKS.
ITS WAS A RIDICULOUS CIRCUS.
THEY WERE WILLING TO SMEAR A
GOOD MAN AND HIS FAMILY FOR
POLITICAL ENDS.
>> Sean: AND NO CORROBORATION,
NO CORROBORATION.
>> YES.
>> Sean: I WATCHED YOU AND I
KNOW YOUR WIFE, HEIDI, GET RUN
OUT OF A RESTAURANT.
WE’VE SEEN IT HAPPEN TO
SECRETARY NIELSEN.
PAM BONDI, SARAH SANDERS, MITCH
McCONNELL.
I DON’T THINK YOU SHOULD LEAVE
THE HALLS OF THE SENATE OPEN.
AND I’M SAYING THAT FOR THE
SAFETY, PROTECTION OF PEOPLE WE
ELECT.
I FEEL FOR EVERYONE’S SAFETY AT
THIS MOMENT.
>> THERE ARE A LOT OF SENATORS
WHO ARE HAVING THAT
CONVERSATION.
MONDAY NIGHT, HEIDI WAS UP IN
D.C. AND THE TWO OF US WENT OUT
ABOUT 9:00 AT NIGHT TO DO A DATE
NIGHT, TWO OF US, WE DON’T GET
TO DO THAT VERY OFTEN.
WE SHOWED UP AT A RESTAURANT
THAT WE LOVE.
UNFORTUNATELY SOMEHOW THE
PROTESTERS WERE THERE WAITING
FOR US AS WE WALKED IN, THEY
SURROUNDED US, THEY SCREAMED AT
US, THEY BASICALLY SHUT DOWN THE
RESTAURANT AND THEY MADE IT
IMPOSSIBLE TO HAVE DINNER.
SO HEIDI AND I GOT UP TO LEAVE,
THEY BLOCKED HER FROM GETTING
OUT.
WHEN WE LEFT THE RESTAURANT,
THIS ACTUALLY HAS NOT BEEN
REPORTED, BUT WE LEFT THE
RESTAURANT, WENT OUT THE DOOR
AND AROUND THE BACK ALLEY.
THIS MOB OF ABOUT 15 SCREAMING
LEFT INTEREST PROTESTERS CHASED
HEIDI AND ME DOWN THE ALLEY
SCREAMING AND YELLING AT US.
A WAITER FROM THE RESTAURANT LET
US IN THE BACK DOOR TO THE
KITCHEN.
AND WE TOOK SHELTER IN THE
KITCHEN WITH THIS SCREAMING MOB
OUTSIDE.
NOW, I TELL YOU A HAPPY ENDING,
ABOUT 10 MINUTES LATER THE
POLICE ARRIVED AND THEY REMOVED
THE PROTESTERS.
AND I ASKED HEIDI, WELL WHAT DO
YOU WANT TO DO, GO SOMEWHERE
ELSE?
SHE SAID NO.
I LIKE THIS RESTAURANT, LET’S
HAVE DATE NIGHT.
WE WENT BACK THROUGH THE
KITCHEN, SAT DOWN AT THE SAME
TABLE AND HAD A DELIGHTFUL
ROMANTIC DINNER.
JUST THE TWO OF US.
>> Sean: GOOD ENDING TO THE
STORY.
SENATOR, YOU’VE ALWAYS STOOD UP
FOR THE CONSTITUTION, DEEPLY
HELD PRINCIPLE’S OF DUE PROCESS.
AND PRESUMPTION OF INNOCENCE.
AND YOUR ELECTION IS IMPORTANT
IN 32 DAYS.
WE WISH YOU ALL THE BEST.